i want to stress from the outset that  this pandemic is  far from over it certainly won't be over  by the 19th  as we predicted in the roadmap in  february we're seeing cases  rise fairly rapidly there could be 50  000 cases detected per day  by the 19th and again as we predicted  we're seeing rising hospital admissions  and we must reconcile ourselves sadly to  more deaths  from kovid in these circumstances we  must take a  careful and a balanced decision  and there's only one reason why we can  contemplate going ahead  to step four in circumstances where we'd  normally be  locking down further and that's because  of the continuing  effectiveness of the vaccine rollout  you